He hasn't been in the ring with Rocky in awhile,
but he's still been pretty busy.
Here's what Carl Weathers has been up to since
his iconic turn as Apollo Creed.
"What do you think you know about me?"
Weathers poked fun at his most famous post-Apollo
role on Saturday Night Live in 2003, reminding
everyone that he will indeed be forever remembered
in the popular imagination as "the black guy
in Predator."
1987's Predator was first and foremost an
Arnold Schwarzenegger film, but it was a big
deal for Weathers at the time, proving he
could be a formidable presence on the big
screen with or without Sylvester Stallone
at his side, which is likely why he soon found
himself headlining his own action film.
1988's Action Jackson could have launched
Weathers into superstardom as the first film
in a lucrative action franchise … but the
film's failing production company was sold
off, and the film was universally panned,
primarily for dialogue like this:
"Barbeque, huh?
How do you like your ribs?"
But Weathers had high hopes: he told Bullz-Eye
in 2009,
"Yeah, people loved Action Jackson.
I get asked all the time, 'Are you ever going
to do a sequel?'
I still maintain today that it could've been
a better movie had we taken a little bit longer
to develop the screenplay, but a lot of people
liked it.
In Germany, it was huge!"
Weathers tried his hand at being an action
star once again in 1992's Hurricane Smith,
think a low-rent Action Jackson set in Australia,
but it wasn't huge anywhere, and it's best
summed up by the alternate international title:
Dead on Delivery.
Weathers wasn't necessarily known for his
comedy skills when his agent steered him toward
Adam Sandler in 1996.
But Weathers soon found himself in Sandler's
Happy Gilmore playing Chubbs Peterson, a former
pro golfer who was forced into retirement
after an alligator bit off his hand.
"I tore one of that bastard's eyes out, though.
Look at that."
"You're pretty sick, Chubbs."
The performance showed the world a different
side of Weathers, which led to further comedy
roles, including on one of the best sitcoms
of all time ...
Although he's only appeared in a grand total
of four episodes over the course of the five
seasons (so far) of Arrested Development,
Weathers relished the opportunity to get a
little goofy by playing an exaggerated version
of himself.
"Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa.
There's still plenty of meat on that bone.
You take this home, throw it in a pot, add
some broth, a potato, baby, you've got a stew
going!"
Series creator Mitchell Hurwitz had originally
contemplated going in a different direction
with Bizarro Carl, one which would've involved
a parody of Rocky and Apollo's beach run in
Rocky III, but when he asked Weathers if he
had any thoughts, Weathers suggested that
maybe he could be really cheap instead.
Hurwitz told Vulture,
"It was so much better.
I went back to the writers room and said,
'You're not going to believe this.
Carl Weathers wants to be incredibly cheap.'
All credit to Carl on that."
After his career in the NFL, but before he
became King of the Morning Shows, Michael
Strahan took a shot at sitcom stardom with
FOX's Brothers.
Weathers played Strahan's dad, and told the
Times-Picayune in advance of the show's September
2009 premiere,
"You see a contemporary black family that
expresses itself with a bit of edge, it's
an edgy show, but at the same time you see
the love."
Unfortunately, the love wasn't shared by the
viewing public: by the end of December, FOX
had already bid adieu to the Brothers.
If you're an old-school cable box channel
surfer, you've likely spotted Weathers popping
up on plenty of shows, from voice work on
the Cartoon Network, to character roles and
award show appearances all across the dial.
After spending a season playing Josh Holloway's
partner on USA's Colony, Weathers added a
new series-regular credit to his name in 2017:
introduced as State's Attorney Mark Jefferies
in an episode of NBC's Chicago P.D., he reprised
the role on Chicago Justice, and an episode
of Law & Order: SVU.
That isn't the only role keeping him busy
lately, either, Weathers also popped up in
an early episode of CBS's rebooted Magnum
P.I. in 2018.